so we're unboxing the pokémon trainer
read champion version this one's a
little bit different than the one
released last year which had the
uninvolved form of three of the Pokemon
contained in this box which is obviously
Charizard lettuce R and Blastoise so
let's open this up the blue box it's
pretty not very interesting now these
are they they're put on these little
stands so you have this plastic bit you
stick into his back then estar comes
with his flower thing
then underneath are their powers you can
see any is another face which you can
also put on the book he said this is a
these are obviously harmed I think it's
it's hands in different positions
this is Charizard attack it looks like
so each Pokemon rather than being
attached to the the individual thing and
see its power with its winds falling off
and it so it's shooting fire up out of
the thing and swings of course fire is
strong against Venus R which is the
grass one uses this grass attack and
Blastoise has a water shooting out of
its last cannons so you can also change
the faces on these I think you can rip
them off head comes off and the
different arms for catching and throw
these please we're gonna lose these
that's pokemon trainer red version with
the evolved Pokemon some of them have
wings
you